This next story is really interesting because
it combines politics with
and with legality and people have been wondering
on our subreddit and phone calls that I've
received, if Nancy Pelosi wanted to, could
she wait to send the articles of impeachment
to the Senate for a trial until a more fair
trial has been agreed to with Senate majority
leader Mitch McConnell, or merely for political
reasons.
Like, if, if Nancy Pelosi says we'd be better
off starting this thing in June when Trump
will be debating the democratic nominee.
Oh, much more, much more, uh, promptly, uh,
soon after.
Could she do that?
And Mitch McConnell, of course, has said,
it's not going to be a fair trial.
He said he will openly coordinate the trial
with Donald Trump, uh, letting the accused
run their own trial or at least influence
it that, uh, Mitch McConnell is not an impartial
juror as required by the constitution.
So there's the question, what if Nancy Pelosi
waits and negotiates?
And that is exactly what she now said is going
to happen.
Nancy Pelosi last night saying, after Donald
Trump had been impeached quote, we have legislation
approved by the rules committee that will
enable us to decide how we will send over
the articles of impeachment.
We cannot name impeachment managers until
we see what the process is on the Senate side.
This may actually be a pretty slick way of
getting some concessions from Republicans
in the Senate or if not of simply, uh, having
the trial at a time that would be more disadvantageous
to Donald Trump.
Because remember, Trump has already talked
about stretching the trial as long as possible
because he believes that would be advantageous
to him.
You know, as he sees it.
It may be true, it may not be the longer the
delay before the trial starts, the longer
that Trump is just an impeached president,
not an acquitted president.
That's interesting.
And of course the longer that the delay goes,
the more likely it is to start overlapping
not only with democratic primaries.
If it goes long enough, it'll start overlapping
with general election debates.
You could conceivably have Donald Trump, uh,
doing campaign spending, buying campaign ads
at the same time that there is an impeachment
trial going on, which is almost like free
money for advertising from the other side.
The fact that there would be an impeachment
trial going on.
I don't think that the trial happening closer
to election day is good for Trump as a big
picture thing, aside from his followers, who
of course will be enraged by the mere fact
that the trial exists.
You know, the more casual voter, the tens
of millions of people who vote, but they don't
follow politics so closely.
If it's getting close to election day and
they know the president is under impeachment
trial, that is going to dissolve some votes
that would otherwise have gone to Donald Trump.
That is the leverage that Nancy Pelosi now
has with the idea of delaying when she's going
to send the articles of impeachment over to
the Senate.
Now, once again, we're speculating about what
the impact might be, but we are once again
in unprecedented territory here.
At a minimum, this throws off Republicans
and Trump because the plan they had Mitch
McConnell's plan was to immediately do a kangaroo
court, which this is what they've been saying
has already gone on.
The real kangaroo court would be the Senate
trial.
Mitch McConnell wants, maybe drag it out,
maybe not, but get the headlines through the
media and then move on with claims of vindication.
Now instead, it's headlines of Trump is impeached.
Trump is impeached, and these are going to
go on for a while without the benefit of the
vindication storylines that would almost certainly
come after an acquittal.
The narrative has been taken from Republicans
and is now Trump has been impeached period,
and that will stay the narrative until Nancy
Pelosi decides she's ready to send impeachment
articles to the Senate.
Trump wants this to move on so that he can
be acquitted and gloat, and now he's going
to have to sit and sit and tweet and sit as
an impeached president, and now Trump is tweeting
that Nancy simply can't do this.
Saying, quote this morning, I got impeached
last night without one Republican vote being
cast with the do nothing.
Dems on their continuation of the greatest
witch hunt in American history.
Now the do nothing.
Dems want to do nothing with the articles
and not deliver them to the Senate, but it's
Senate's call.
Does an impeached president have international
credibility?
Among other world leaders.
I don't know.
It doesn't sound like it's too good for Trump.
What's that phrase that Don jr used?
Um, about the Russian lawyer meeting something
like if it's what you say, I love it, especially
later in the summer.
I think it applies doubly here, particularly
if this thing even conceivably stretches,
uh, beyond spring and at some point we will
figure out what the timing of it is.
But uh, I think there are many criticisms
of Nancy Pelosi.
I do think it was a mistake not to include
emoluments in the impeachment articles, but
this is pretty slick and I think it may actually
work even if it only works to send Trump again
off the rails.
That probably in and of itself
is worthwhile.